franki ice Frank Isola from the New York
Daily News Frank he caught my attention
when it was great the Knicks got a new
head coach David fishtail but all of a
sudden you started to attach LeBron
James name to this how much of a role do
you think that played if any in phys
Dale being hired as the Nixon what oh I
definitely think how you doing Dan I
don't think that it has obviously
something to do it because the Knicks
for selling this idea after the season
that they were looking for a coach that
could connect with today's players that
has relationships with them by then they
had already reached out to David fizz
Dale and you know obviously Davis
Tisdale in his time with the man heat
organization close relationship with
LeBron Dwyane Wade it's always a little
bit different to when you're the
assistant coach but go back Tony was
fired by Memphis member LeBron Dwyane
Wade really came out and were you know
LeBron I think his Connell was I'm gonna
need some answers has to fly my but he
did this Dale got fired I think that's
always in the back of the next mind and
I think LeBron could be a free agent
this summer could be a free agent next
summer the Knicks will have money so I
think that definitely has a little bit
to do with it but if you looked at the
Knicks situation 76ers or Lakers if you
if you're LeBron here why would you for
any reason other than hey I like Coach
phys Dale go to the Knicks well I think
a couple of things number one what's
porzingis who's helps gonna be there's
gonna be out all the next season that
obviously changes things can you make a
couple of moves to try to bring somebody
in that changes it as well but when the
playoffs started this year in the East a
lot of people are saying well look at
the Cavs only it used to have Kyrie and
Kevin Love now he's only got Kevin Love
is second guy they're not that good of a
team now here they are they look like
the best team once again in the Eastern
Conference because that's how good
LeBron is so if you put a halfway decent
roster around LeBron and he's going to
be the centerpiece of it in the east
you're gonna rule and I that's my thing
about him with going to the Lakers and I
think most people believe could be the
Lakers could be Euston if he ends up
leaving the Cavaliers but you know
you're going into the belly of the beast
if you go to the Lakers especially you
got Houston and you have golden ticket
you have to compete with when we know in
the Eastern Conference
nobody has beaten him four times in
seven games since she went to my
at the start of the 2010-11 season and
it looks like that's probably gonna be
the case this year as well nobody in the
East can beat this guy how concerned
would you be with that falling out in
Memphis it felt like it was David phys
Dale and Marcus Saul and they were at
odds with each other and then they
decided to part with phys Dale is that I
have to be careful too mentioning that
because I had the audacity to mention
that in my story of Nick man got all
upset it's certainly part of it I mean
he was there for 101 games and they
ended up firing him mostly because of
his poor relationship with Mark Isola
that doesn't mean that it's all day
because Dale's fault it certainly
doesn't mean that he won't have a great
rapport with his players here but in his
first stint as a head coach he was
feuding with his best player and it's
not really no no I think like a soul is
somewhat outspoken a bit of a free
spirit but he was never really viewed as
a malcontent before so I don't know how
much you could put on him so I think
it's something it certainly has to be in
the back of your mind and that's
something I'm sure the Knicks had to
consider when they brought him in but
remembered and they're kind of painting
him as the player with me yeah in some
ways yeah all right well this is part of
the story - his relationship with Marc
Gasol again it was his first ever job
since then he's been quoted as saying
it's something I have to learn from
player coach relationships and all guys
don't always get along I I agree with
him and that doesn't mean he won't do a
good job but it certainly as you just
pointed out it's part of the story when
do you think it happened where free
agents stop considering New York as a
destination I think some Nick fans will
tell you it's because of the lowlifes of
the media that's why players don't want
to continue I think some of it has to do
there's a lot of things you know it's
been a losing organization somewhat
dysfunctional so I think when you arrive
in New York and I think Amar'e
Stoudemire was willing to embrace it
Carmelo Anthony was willing to embrace
the kind of the pressure that comes
along with you're gonna be the savior
but I think there's a lot of players
that don't want to deal with that I
think there are probably some players to
that figure you know what I love going
to New York just like I love going to
Atlanta but I really don't want to play
there year-round I don't really want to
live there with my family we're not
really that the New York scene so to
speak so I think there's been a lot of
reasons
why why that has been the case and it's
um it frustrates Nick bands absolutely
but look at it this way
you know Russell Westbrook is in every
darn commercial you ever see please in
Oklahoma City you know it's a I just
sorry Anthony Davis yesterday in
commercials now he plays in New Orleans
so the idea that you have to play in you
know the biggest market and the NBA
playoffs this year going along pretty
well you don't have LA you don't have
Chicago and you don't have New York in
the playoffs I guess I'm just curious
the poor singers situation is what's
really interesting there of just how
serious this surgery was in the rehab
and coming back so you know trying to
attract somebody you know I know the
Knicks played hard
hornacek probably didn't get a fair
shake but I just can't imagine any of
the you know Paul George doesn't mention
going to New York or yeah you know some
of these other guys who have that
opportunity just nobody mentions New
York anymore and to your point you know
David Tuesday laughter he got fired from
Memphis was doing a lot of TV work and
he was actually quoted he was on TV the
day that the Brazilian news came down
about the injury and he's and he said
something along the lines of you know I
thought New York would be a place where
they could attract players because of
porzingis now I don't think that's the
case oh I don't think he's going to
mention that at his press conference
that we're you know really the one
attraction besides the garden and all
the other stuff was presenting us and I
think he'll players want to know if
they're going to have a chance to win I
think a lot of guys looking for zingers
has a very interesting player but he
might you know the owner Jim Dolan said
about was about a month ago he threw out
there the possibility that prisoners
could be at the entire year next year so
that sets you back another season are
you one around the horn today yes I am I
heard I guess Tony really made he wants
you to be on the show yeah I know I
haven't received an official offer
though Frank but he is a good he is a
good idea though he wants it to be you
Keith Olbermann and a couple and a
couple other guys which I think would be
smart I think but see here was what I
said when he brought this up on the air
I was like a Dan Patrick doesn't neither
work we know he doesn't need the money
why are you trying to get rid of me on
the show and I know you guys
do well which will only make it worse
for the rest of us then he'll turn it
into celebrity around the horn and
you'll never see me on there it goes no
I don't want to do that I do think it
yeah so why do you think it would be
good TV it's not good for my career at
this point that's all I'm concerned
about wow there's so many of you writers
I'd love to take down
I mean I'd start with Callie Shaw I'd
bring Mariotti back for a cameo what do
you think well you know what we're not
that hard to believe about people in the
business like the players that we cover
the coaches the front office and then
like you know you guys came up in TV and
radio really the biggest babies and if
everyone are always the newspaper guys
like if you come after us that's when we
really bite back we can't take the
criticism we could certainly dish it out
I want to say one more thing okay every
time I think of you I think of the great
when you used to do the reports with
after the NBA Finals games with the
great late Jack Rams
yes he used to say and he begin every
sentence as well and I'll I used to love
that you guys were great he was you know
what I had so much respect for Jack and
because he coached my favorite
basketball team of all time the Blazers
with Bill Walton yeah but the number of
players and I'm talking Hall of Famers
future Hall of Famers who would come and
talk to him after games in the NBA
Finals Hakeem Olajuwon came to Jack
Ramsey after every game of the NBA
Finals and he said dr. Jack what did you
see and and only if you went to him
would he give you advice and he would it
was like he was mr. Miyagi it was really
incredible and he'd said it's such a
great heart and he just wanted everybody
to get better and even Jordan would talk
to dr. Jack about that and so very
giving very giving man you know he was
such a gentleman but like the two of you
in that setting when you it was just
great it works you know the chemistry
was good it was always really
entertaining thank you Frank thank you
have fun tonight on around the horn
Frank I saw New York Daily News for more
Dan Patrick show too
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]